- [Instructor] We are asked,
who is a secondary consumer
in this diagram?
So pause this video, and see
if you can figure that out.
Alright, now let's work
through this together.
So let's just make sure we
understand this diagram.
When we have an arrow
from grasses to mouse,
it means that the grasses
go into the mouse's mouth.
It means that the mouse eats the grasses.
Similarly, the grasshopper
eats the grasses.
And then we have these
arrows from the mouse,
to the coyote, the hawk,
the snake, the vulture.
That means that all of these
characters may eat the mouse.
Likewise, a hawk eats a grasshopper.
So now that we understand this diagram,
let's label where these various
folks fit in the food chain.
So the grasses right over here,
they are a primary producer.
They are using photosynthesis
in order to take
light energy from the sun in
conjunction with carbon dioxide
in the air and water, in order
to store energy in its bonds.
Now the grasshopper and
the mouse eat that grass
for that energy.
And so, the grasshopper and the mouse,
since they directly eat
that primary producer,
they would be primary...
Primary consumers.
Consumers.
And I think you see where this is going.
The folks who then eat
the primary consumers,
so this would be the hawk,
the coyote, the vulture,
and the snake, these would
all be secondary consumers.
Secondary...
Secondary consumers.
And we're done.
Who is a secondary
consumer in this diagram?
We could say the coyote's
a secondary consumer.
The hawk is also a secondary consumer.
The vulture is a secondary consumer.
And so is the snake.
And as you can see, that's
okay, even in a situation
where some secondary consumers eat
other secondary consumers.
The coyote might eat a hawk,
or a vulture might eat a snake,
and a coyote might eat a
vulture, which eats a snake,
which might eat a mouse,
which eats the grass.
But any of these could be
considered secondary consumers.